McConnell did you see him freeze like
the clown from the It movie now Mitch
McConnell's in deep trouble apparently
he fell at the airport and then they let
him get up there and he gave the speech
and he just paused I think he flatlined
for a couple seconds he's 82
years old why do we keep rolling
these 80 to 90 year old
politicians out people retire at like 65
am I right the medium age for retirement
is what 65 okay get it people are living
longer now so what 72 all right but what
the is an 84 year old guy doing a
very important job the Senate Majority
Leader is almost as powerful as the
president a lot of people don't
understand that and this guy's 84. can
we have a sweet little retirement party
for this guy up on Capitol Hill please
I'd like to go into one of those
buildings and get a piece of cake a
slice of cake and say thank you for your
service go enjoy applesauce my guy the
applesauce years have been upon you